all right my review of a movie that came
out on Friday on Tuesday when the movie
came in fourth on its opening weekend
[Music]
draft day so draft day stars Kevin
Costner and it takes place on the NFL
draft day yeah it all takes place in one
day I like movies that take place in one
day
draft a training day can be surprising
how much can happen in one day and
draftees ultimately Kevin Costner who's
trying to scheme with these people and
those people he's calling these people
making deals here and then he's calling
these people these people are calling
him he's making deals here it shows the
workings of what goes on behind the
scenes in a draft day he's trying to get
this one dude but he's like does this
guy have enough heart gene Hackman in
The Replacements Kevin Costner and draft
day what we're learning is that to play
a proper football
you need to have heart and that's
interesting that's exciting and when it
was all going down in the last 45
minutes of the movie it was really cool
everything leading up to it I was like
it's interesting enough but let's just
get to the draft day although it is on
draft day but let's get to the draft 3
the last part of this movie the draft
that's really intense it's really
interesting a lot of cogs a lot of gears
are turning I understand a lot of my
demographic they're not sports people so
we'll talk like magic arts ultimately
these NFL players some their mythic
rares other people are rares who do you
trade 2 or 3 rares for a mythic rare
it's kind of what it's like it's what
Kevin Costner has to deal with in this
movie and there's a romance between him
and Jennifer Garner but ultimately in
the romance you're like I okay and Kevin
Costner's stressed out in that day and
she's expecting a baby find this out at
the beginning of the movie they don't
feel like it really played into anything
you feel like if he wasn't dating
Jennifer Garner if she wasn't kind of
pissed at him throughout this movie if
she wasn't pregnant he would still be
stressed to [ __ ] because of his job so
at that point I look at I'm like what's
the point of a romance I guess in every
movie I have to have a romance somewhere
you don't but that's the mindset I guess
I like Denis Leary in this movie of
course he's the coach is like your draft
picks are [ __ ] you know I'm quitting
I'm quitting pretty much he's the Philip
Seymour Hoffman in Moneyball but for
this movie you look at this movie it
really is a Moneyball kind of movie you
know the guy who's making the weird
drafts and the weird picks is gonna make
a team that actually works for I'm not
conventional but it works and everyone
else is like I you're Pixar [ __ ] don't
do that I we have no faith in you but
this is underdog story shows how
decisions that are not conventional can
still be good ones
money football that's what draft day is
ultimately draft day was funny Kevin
Costner was good in it I'm glad Kevin
Costner's getting work again but the
build-up was just a lot of talk and you
get it cuz he has to talk to people and
he has to set up what will be the draft
moment he has to lay the groundwork for
the epic that's to come even in the
draft moment it was interesting for me
to watch but is it more interesting than
being interested in football and
watching an actual NFL Draft feel like
football fans would just eat up the
actual event the movie was interesting
enough there were enough jokes to keep
it chuckling I'm not gonna look in the
eyes and say you this is the movie you
need to see today you like seeing the
intensity and strategy that goes behind
something like this by the end of the
movie I actually had fun with this so I
will say draft day is a good time no
alcohol required right so what's your
favorite sports movie of all time
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]